♪ ♪
SPEAK OF PRESIDENT HAS NEVER
FELT TITLE 42 WAS AN EFFECTIVE
IMMIGRATION POLICY AND HE TALKED
ABOUT THAT DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE
BASICALLY SAYING TITLE 42 IS THE
USELESS AFTER A FEDERAL JUDGE
ISSUED A TEMPORARY RESTRAINING
ORDER ON BIDEN'S PLAN TO END THE
TRUMP ARROW BORDER POLICY THAT
HAS BEEN MASSIVELY EFFECTIVE AT
STOPPING MIGRANTS.
THE FALLOUT CONTINUES FROM THE
TRAGIC DEATH OF 22-YEAR-OLD
TEXAS NATIONAL GUARDSMEN BISHOP
EVANS WHO DROWNED WHILE TRYING
TO SAVE MIGRANTS IN THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER.
THE WHITE HOUSE TRIES TO DENY
ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
DEATH, DISMISSING HIM AS A STATE
EMPLOYEE.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT IS
MAKING IT CLEAR WHO WAS AT
FAULT.
SPEAK IT WE WOULD NOT HAVE TO
HAVE A NATIONAL GUARD ON THE
BORDER IF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS VERY SIMPLY
ENFORCING THE LAWS PASSED BY THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
SECURING OUR BORDER.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
START DYING.
>> Dana: THE BORDER PATROL,
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN,
FIRST RESPONDERS, THEY HAVE DONE
AMAZING WORK.
THE CHILDREN THEY SAVED, THE
BABIES THEY SAVED.
YOU ONLY HEAR ABOUT THESE TRAGIC
SITUATIONS LIKE WITH BISHOP
EVANS BECAUSE IT WENT SO WRONG
FOR HIM.
SOMETIMES A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
WILL SAY SOMETHING THAT TAKES
YOUR BREATH AWAY.
THE THOUGHT THAT HE WAS JUST A
STATE EMPLOYEE.
THAT'S BEING DISMISSIVE.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WAS
NECESSARILY INTENDED BUT IT CAME
ACROSS AS VERY CRASS.
>> Geraldo: TOTALLY NOT
INTENDED.
SHE DIDN'T WANT --
>> Dana: WHY SAY IT ANYWAY?
>> Geraldo: IT LOOKED LIKE A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIG AT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
>> Dana: THERE WAS A WAY TO
SAY NOTHING.
TITLE 42 IS HEADED IN THE SAME
DIRECTION THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS TRIED.
THEY PUT OUT A POLICY OR TRY TO
HIDE BEHIND A POLICY AND THE
COURT STRIKE IT DOWN.
YOU HAD YOUR DEPORTATION
MORATORIUM.
AND REMAINED MEXICO.
VACCINE MANDATES.
THE FREEZE ON OIL AND GAS LEASES
PREDICATES STOPPED BY THE
COURTS.
THEN OH, SORRY.
>> Jesse: IT'S A LAWLESS
PRESIDENT.
ANY TIME TRUMP DID SOMETHING
THAT GOT STRUCK DOWN, LAWLESS
PRESIDENT.
GERALDO, LOOKED LIKE YOU WERE
CHOMPING AT THE BIT.
>> Geraldo: POLICY IS ONE
THING BUT WHEN YOU GET TO BE MY
AGE ON YOU LOOK AT THESE
PICTURES AND YOU SEE THESE
PEOPLE.
WHAT'S THE POLICY?
YOU SEE THE BABIES.
THEY DESPERATELY WANT WHAT
AMERICA PROMISES.
I WAS A LATIN CORRESPONDENT FOR
ABC.
THE WARS IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
THEY HAVE THE SHORT END OF THE
STATE.
AMERICA CAN'T TAKE EVERYBODY.
I DID A BAD JOB EXPLAINING TITLE
42 YESTERDAY.
I WANT ANOTHER SHORT CRACK AT
IT.
COURTS HAVE SAID YOU CAN'T END
TITLE 42 AND YOU CAN'T AND
REMAIN IN MEXICO.
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
PRESSURING DEMOCRATS TO MAKE A
LAW THAT ACCOMPLISHES THE RESULT
OF REMAINING IN MEXICO WHICH
MAKES SENSE.
THEY COME THROUGH MEXICO TO
CLAIM ASYLUM HERE.
LET THEM STAY IN MEXICO.
I UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE.
MAY NOT BE 100% BEHIND IT.
YOU NEED LAWS.
EXECUTIVE ORDERS, THEY COME AND
GO.
ONE ADMINISTRATION IS ONE THING.
WHEN YOU HAVE A LAW AND THE LIES
BEEN TESTED IN COURT
CONSTITUTIONALLY, THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY.
OUR HEARTS ARE GOING TO KEEP
BREAKING AND TERRIBLE CASES WILL
HAPPEN.
>> Judge Jeanine: WE DON'T
NEED COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO FOLLOW THE
LAW.
>> Geraldo: HOW DO YOU WANT TO
STOP THEM?
DO YOU WANT TO SHOOT THEM?
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU ASKED ME
A QUESTION.
LET ME ANSWER IT.
STOP THEM BY MAKING, BY HAVING A
WALL, THAT'S NUMBER ONE BUT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
STOP THEM BY DOING EVERYTHING
JOE BIDEN IS NOT DOING.
JOE BIDEN IS DOING EVERYTHING HE
CAN TO BRING EVERYONE, EVERYONE
TO MAKE THE UNITED STATES A
GLOBAL WAVING SPOT WHERE
EVERYONE WHO PAYS TAXES GETS TO
PAY FOR ALL THEIR EDUCATION,
MEDICATION, HOUSING, FOOD,
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
LET ME TELL YOU.
HE IS NOT JUST LEAVING THE
BORDER OPEN.
HE'S ACTUALLY INSTITUTING
POLICIES TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THEM TO GET IN.
SO GIVE THEM AN ALTERNATIVE TO
DETENTION.
GIVE THEM A NOTICE TO APPEAR.
GIVE THEM A CELL PHONE.
AND THEN YOU PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE ABILITY TO GO TO THE
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY.
YOU GO TO COURT TO FIGHT AGAINST
IT.
IN DOING SO, YOU ALLOW
UNVACCINATED ILLEGALS AND FIGHT
IN COURT FOR THEIR RIGHT TO COME
IN UNVACCINATED.
THEN YOU APPEAL A DECISION BY A
FEDERAL JUDGE THAT SAYS WE DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS, FEELING THAT
DECISION SAYING I WANT AMERICANS
TO WEAR MASKS.
WAIT A MINUTE.
WHILE THEY ARE NOW ON THE
SUPREME COURT FIGHTING TO AND
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
WHICH FORCES THEM TO STAY IN
MEXICO.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO CHANGE
AMERICA, TO PUT A BURDEN ON ALL
OF US AND STOP WITH THIS "POOR
THEM."
THEY CAN COME HERE LEGALLY.
WHEN MY FAMILY CAME -- WE ARE
LEBANESE.
WE CAME.
THEY KISSED THE GROUND OF THE
UNITED STATES.
MY FATHER FOUGHT IN
WORLD WAR II.
MY GRANDFATHER FOUGHT IN
THEY COULDN'T WAIT TO DEFEND
THIS COUNTRY SO STOP.
>> Geraldo: LOTS OF MEXICANS
FOUGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU TRY TO
SEND THEM HOME AND THEY WILL
KICK AND SCREAM THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO GO HOME.
>> Jesse: STOP WITH THE
HOGWASH, GERALDO.
>> Geraldo: DON'T YOU HAVE ANY
COMPASSION?
>> Jesse: I HAVE MORE
COMPASSION AND MY LITTLE PINKY,
GERALDO.
GO AHEAD, GREG.
>> Greg: I AM TIRED.
THAT WAS KIND OF EXHAUSTING.
IT'S A RUNNING PROBLEM, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE FIRST SEGMENT ON
TWITTER, MUSK, THIS SEGMENT ON
THE BORDER AND NOW WE ARE GOING
TO DO CRIME.
THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY
STICKS OUT THE POSITIONS KNOWING
THAT THEY ARE DESTRUCTIVE SIMPLE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BE SEEN
AGREEING WITH THE OTHER SIDE.
THEY BUILD THEIR OWN PRISON BY
DEMONIZING ANYBODY ELSE OUTSIDE
OF IT.
IF WE WERE AGAINST THE WALL THEY
WOULD'VE BEEN FOR IT.
IF THERE WAS A REPUBLICAN IN
CHARGE RIGHT NOW IN A PARALLEL
UNIVERSE THEY WOULD BE
PLASTERING THE STORY
AROUND-THE-CLOCK.
THEY WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
DEAD TEXAS NATIONAL GUARDSMEN IS
SOMETHING -- THEY WERE TREATED
LIKE A HUGE STORY.
THEY CAN'T BE SEEN IN BED WITH
REPUBLICANS.
THEY CAN'T BE SEEN AGREEING WITH
US.
SO INSTEAD WHAT THEY DO IS THEY
THROW COMPASSION OUT THE WINDOW.
THE WAY JEN PSAKI ANSWER THAT
QUESTION YESTERDAY WAS LIKE,
"NOT OUR FAULT.
THAT'S ON THEM."
SHE KNEW FOR TWO YEARS IT'S BEEN
A PROBLEM AND THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE WILLING ACTUALLY
SACRIFICE PEOPLE AT THI